ich will heiraten in der schweiz mit
groupe mutuel versicherungen
clubmitglied seit 20 jahren für sie da
[Musik]
von vier paaren handeln dieser
geschichten von menschen die sich dazu
entscheiden das abenteuer einer ehe zu
wahren indem sie ja sagen zum geliebten
menschen sagen sie auch ja zur
vorgeschichte des gegenübers zur
herkunft und zur verwandtschaft mit
allen eigenheiten und vorzügen
[Musik]
oli bärtschi hat aus einer früheren
beziehung einen sohn den 13 jährigen
pascal pascal wohnt bei seiner mutter
verbringt seine freie zeit aber sehr
gerne bei seinem papa dass pascal heute
da ist hat einen besonderen grund
zusammen mit oldies zukünftiger frau
andrea buchecker und onkel daniel
begleitet er seinen papa zu einer
regionalen fischer letzte woche erzählte
andrea buchecker und willibert wie sich
ihre herzen gefunden haben
die beiden gehörlosen manuela egger und
christian hilfiker hoben ab und auf über
3000 meter über meer machte er ihr den
heiratsantrag
schwer trägt christian reich an seiner
eigenen vergangenheit die ihm das
etikett des scheinheirat das eingetragen
hat und eine serbisch orthodoxe
traumhochzeit soll es für aldiana
novakovic und räten petkovic werden
andrea wusste von anfang an als sie mit
uli zusammen kam dass dieser bereits
einen sohn hat den inzwischen
13-jährigen pascal
[Musik]
wenn andrea ihre murli diesen sommer das
ja wort gibt dann sagt sie auch jahr zu
seiner vergangenheit in erster linie
aber denken sie an die gemeinsame
zukunft mit eigenen kindern weniger nach
kindern sondern nach kindern steht juli
in diesem augenblick der sinn
ein spezieller tag ist heute auch für
christian hilfiger und manuela egger
die beiden sind ins bayerische alter den
gefahren in manuelas heimat zusammen mit
manuel us mutter maria wollen sie für
christian einen hochzeitsanzug kaufen
[Applaus]
manuela und christian sind seit über
fünf jahren ein paar
kennengelernt hatten sie sich 2008 an
der silvesterparty für gehörlose in wien
manuelas eltern waren im ersten moment
nicht begeistert darüber dass ihre
tochter bald darauf in die schweiz nach
oftringen umzog
doch schnell war ihnen klar dass manuela
und christian füreinander die richtigen
sind
ich hätte man keine besten spielers und
wünschen können wir es jetzt ganz
ehrlich sagen ich hab gesagt ich hätte
mir keinen besseren schwiegersohn
wünschen können aber das heißt weg das
ist das passt es ist wert von den
übergang ist auch firmen kleiner gelernt
haben es war okay christian und manuela
waren schon vor ein paar wochen hier und
haben sich für einen anzug entschieden
[Gelächter]
alle müssen mit anpacken wenn juli mit
seinem tier an diesem kalten frühlings
tag an der viehschau eine gute
klassierung erreichen
die tournee hat sich andrea für einen
mann entschieden der weiß was er will
und er auch gerne klare anweisungen
erteilt
[Musik]
durch den kauf nur noch wenige
augenblicke hat uli zeit für die letzten
details gleich wird er zur präsentation
in den ring steigen wann immer sich im
ochsen in rüti diese herren runde trifft
kommt früher oder später die
geheimnisvolle geliebte von christian
reich zur sprache
aber da bin ich keine babys sind das int
auch romantik sind vom herz und drosch
bewiesen
sie wird irgendwann duffy und dann käme
dann wettert sich bewerben
das ist das bewies sie hat zweimal welt
vitro mit dem touristenvisum und das
spiel mal abgelehnt wurde vor der
schweizer botschaft in santo domingo und
dann habe ich ja jetzt muss man halt
einfach wie heute
wobei ich bin ja mal von natürlichen
kilometer andere und darum habe ich sie
dann in konter von trainer patrick
meehan das gerät einfach jede diagnose
und hans gefiel das ist
in puerto plata in der dominikanischen
republik lebt sie die 30 jahre jüngere
große liebe namens bienvenido dank
finanzieller unterstützung von christian
kann sie sich um ihre eltern kümmern um
den blinden vater pablo del carmen und
um mutter capita diese erkennt die
eigene tochter nicht mehr kapital ist
mit 77 jahren genau gleich alt wie
christian sie leidet seit langem an
demenz hier in der dominikanischen
republik ist es selbstverständlich dass
man sich nicht nur um die eltern sondern
um alle betagten kümmert natürlich ist
es nicht einfach ihr schicksal zu
akzeptieren aber es ist so wie es ist
[Musik]
so sieht ein stolzer bräutigam aus es
wird noch an der länge christian hilfe
kathrin voss eine braut manuela und
deren mutter maria elegant manuela und
christian sind gleichermaßen begeistert
mit ausnahme der schule
sie drücken
die brauchen und das oft perfekt sehr
schön edel gut gemacht und du brauchst
keine angst haben ist passt zum teil
sie sind eine große angst dass er nicht
zu mir passt aber manuela ist die ältere
von zwei schwestern und sie ist marias
erste tochter die heiratet bis jetzt war
ich nicht nervös
das kleinkind hatte ein kleines kind
etwas anderes wie ein gesundes kind
schon ihres babys waren unterschiedlich
auf jeden fall
[Musik]
in villingen im kanton baselland trifft
sich heute die familie petkovic treten
eltern haben zu einem wichtigen
serbisch-orthodoxen familienfest
eingeladen
auch das brautpaar ist da die familie
schützling auf das ist jedes jahr am
gleichen datums in die familie nimmt am
der heilige nikolaus unter dem motto
stars und das brotbacken und damit die
krieger und dann wird das vom 5
dass die heiligen und eingestellt und
dann tut mir der demo mit familie und
miteinander schön lustig wenn wir das
idiotische familien das war mir so viel
weil ich als mein schutzengel und
umsetzung ihrer familie und allem drum
und dran das ist einfach so habe ich das
ein fremder mit klappt einfach wieder
auf und das schönste daran gestört
[Musik]
als extra schmuckhandel hätte das nicht
selber in auftrag gegen die us-ermittler
goldschmied so wie sie wünsche so
weitergehe und uns zu stellen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie hat unbedingt steigern
meine man bringe nicht viel falsch
machen
aber wäre ständig party vor stein und
accenture
für uli und seine crew tiffany gilt es
ernst
die nervosität kann der sonst so
selbstsichere bauer jetzt nicht mehr
ganz verbergen
[Musik]
ja
willibert sie weiß die aufmerksamkeit
der jury auf sich respektive auf tiefer
nie zu lenken
[Musik]
auch christian reich hat ein paar
errungenschaften oft ihr besonders stolz
ist das sich dreht stäbe vor dem lsg
klinik steckt hat juni ab ich bin sehr
sehr glücklich
das tut mal mehr biss und ich liebe dich
und jetzt müssen wir einfach noch
private bekannte mit denen mit true dank
schämen oder mit der hand um 14 566
richtig je älter man wird umso weniger
wichtig ist zu sechs heißt tag merkt zu
setzen
der wagen blieb da hab ich auch ich
kenne sie und sagt ich werde die pd
und ich kann sicher nicht gesucht nach
einer frau
ich bin ich hotel haben zwei wochen
abschalten und dann habe ich halt
tropfen in dem laden in dem motto zieh
meter abschnitten hat und sido habe
kontakt klettertag eto'o auch das
einzigste august 2008
es ist nicht als sollte sich zeit auf
das ist grossartig nebenher verdienen
absolute priorität gar nicht reden und
das marketing die haut ab und dann so
wenig zahlen und so ist gut und so kann
ich weiter und ich dann kann natürlich
vor allem an die zukunft ich will die
schweiz dort käme das theater heute malt
und dort man ihn etwa und ich hatte dann
eine parade sind 150 quadratmeter
in der schweiz gibt es ein halbes
dutzend serbisch orthodoxe kirchen eine
davon steht in schwamendingen hier
wollen aldiana und treten in ein paar
wochen heiraten und diese immer wieder
zeigt wo er mehrere wo sind diese wurzel
oder auch vor der vorfahren und mich
sind das alles schön sei es wichtig sein
für die kinder
wir waren das dass das lied abstellen
dabei ist sie nicht zu mögen die ihre
herkunft vergessen und sagen so jetzt
ist es so sondern mir sind die hände
gebunden
das wahrhaftig zusammen mit seitens
eltern und den pfarrer miroslaw
simonovic ihren aldiana und treten den
ablauf ihrer trauer begleitet und jetzt
schon wieder 30
und wenn provisorisch
in der schweiz leben rund 80.000
menschen die der serbisch-orthodoxen
kirche angehören
zur kirchlichen tradition gehört unter
anderem dass der pfarrer zuerst den
bräutigam und dann auch der braut
während der trauung die krone aufsetzt
das ständig komplexer es nur dort
da ikeas das hat der trend nur okay wenn
er schneidet orte in der lehre
unterdessen ob du sagen jedoch saniert
duschen oder kochen krone bedeutet dass
davor oder symbolen von dir bin also mit
dem königlichen setzten dann sind das
symbol für liebe jetzt einfacher mit und
dann gibt es auch wieder gebaut
und da gibt es laufen
[Musik]
da was
in bayern unweit der stadt münchen ist
manuela egger aufgewachsen
obwohl sie in der schweiz lebt besucht
sie ihre eltern und die oma alle paar
wochen
heute ist auch ihre freundin carmen
daniela war ein jahr alt erfahren dass
sie nicht hört und am hammer kurze zeit
später einen gebärden kurs gebracht und
sie hat sich gebärden gelernt wie andere
kinder sprechen lernen und so sieht ist
in die gewährten reingewachsen
und du hast mit deiner muttersprache
aufwachsen
das wissen du bist groß geworden mit
gebärdet und die sprechen hast du dann
später mühsam erlernen was und wie
schwer aber ich hab's ja gerne gemacht
hast du mich zu stimmen weil ich musste
keine neue grammatik lernen das ist
jetzt die gleiche sprache tun was nicht
so schwer und ich wollte ja mit meinem
mehrere reden können
deine erste gebärde war vogel
das werde ich nie vergessen damals dann
eineinhalb jahre alt manuela ist ohne
christian hier
denn sie will mit ihren freundinnen in
münchen polterabend feiern zum lauf der
dinge auf einem bauernhof gehört dass
der vater eines tages dem sohn die
geschicke überträgt genau so geschah es
vor vier jahren auch mit olli und seinem
vater rudi idee für die junge generation
und ich probiere halt machen und
einfache methode tierbestandes recht
machen
fertig
während uli für vater und mutter das
stück gebaut und zwar so wie es ihm am
besten gefällt übernimmt der vater die
arbeiten im stall und auch er tut das so
wie er es für richtig hält
[Applaus]
nachfolger wird mir doch nicht groß und
doch er holt aber sei es der fahrer
sauber machen oder zu jeder zeit
[Musik]
in den letzten monaten hat ulrike seine
eltern ruhe die und immer auf dem hofe
ein modernes kleines stück gebaut
[Musik]
juli verwirklicht beim stöckli er seine
eigenen und andreas vorstellungen
weniger die nächte hinter die große der
woche und dann denkt denn der muss für
sie harmonieren es muss auch selber
besser zu möbel zum stein
und wie sieht es ist grün in dem eine
mit rot oder mit prägen wir müssen jetzt
aufwachen
inzwischen sind aldiana und treten
ebenfalls nach münchen gefahren
drittens anzug kostet hier bedeutend
weniger als in der schweiz
er zeigt seiner braut wasser mit den
eltern ausgesucht hat
es ist nicht zu groß - und bin
mir gefällt nicht nur zu lang auch zu
breit ich habe das gefühl da könnt ihr
schwimmen in diesen hosen also hänger
machen ja das ist meine schuld
er hat sich einfach sehen sind alles
zwar aus gestein das ganze gleich so was
muss ich gucken was sie fühlen kann
die bestimmung zu dick
in sachen auf der uhr wir haben sie ganz
dubai mit womit beerdigungs gesucht
haben welchen vorstellen und jetzt hat
sie das haben uns die rosen aber das ist
ja so diese sind im bezirk los
[Musik]
vergeblich hat christian reich bisher
versucht sei libyen wieder in die
schweiz zu bringen weil er bereits
viermal verheiratet war zuletzt mit zwei
frauen aus der dominikanischen republik
machen die behörden nicht mehr jeden
hochzeitstanz des 77 jährigen mit wieder
sie sehen muss er zu ihr
ja ich hätte mir bleibt was mir das noch
mal passiert dass ich schon unglaublich
ehefrau camille darum ist das paket für
mich herrlich
ja ja
[Musik]
punta cana ja gern
ich habe schon genau uns gelassen
[Musik]
polterabend für manuela und ihre
freundinnen oder junggesellenabschied
wie das in bayern heißt so oder so die
jungen frauen sind gut ausgerüstet für
ihr kleines abenteuer
studiert man gebeten
also raus muss
[Musik]
manuela arbeitet in der schweiz als
laborantin heute es war sie überprüfen
ob die chemie zwischen ihr und der
münchner männerwelt stimmt helfen können
notfalls die kleinen spirituosen die sie
für einen euro das stück verkauft
[Musik]
also
manuelas aufregung und bedenken waren
umsonst
sie erledigt ihre aufgabe mit bravour
nur wenige kilometer entfernt kostet
tretens anzug zwar ein paar franken
weniger dafür ein paar nerven mehr als
geplant
also im programm vorstellen
speziell treten ist in der
immobilienbranche tätig zu seinem
markenzeichen gehört dass er stets gerne
und auch geschickt verhandelt auch heute
holte ein paar prozent der rabatt für
den anzug heraus
da haben wir schon lange nicht bekannt
manuelas befürchtung heißt könnten wegen
des kühlen frühlingswetters zu wenige
männer in münchens kassen unterwegs
seien aber unbegründet
der fc bayern münchen feiert an diesem
tag den meistertitel
und manuela und ihre freundinnen sind
nicht die einzigen die einen
junggesellenabschied feiern
[Musik]
alle fotos
der sender über nicht
[Musik]
so manuelas überraschung fährt plötzlich
eine stretchlimousine vor
[Applaus]
erst jetzt erfährt manuela dass die
limousine die idee ihrer trauzeugin mia
rotbuche war
[Musik]
während die stimmung bei den jungen
frauen besser nicht sein könnte haben
aldiana und räten einen
nervenaufreibenden nachmittag hinter
sich
jetzt gestand ich bin zu finden sind ja
auch zufügen ja ich sowieso trotz ich
bin jetzt auch zufrieden
alle mühen haben sich gelohnt die
strapazen sind vergessen dass necken hat
ein ende
[Gelächter]
nach einem rund zehnstündigen flug hat
christian reich in punta cana wieder
festen boden unter den füßen und wie er
sagt das paradies auf erden vor sich wie
an der nidda ist zusammen mit ihrem
bruder benny hergekommen um christian
abzuholen
nie
die fahrt nach puerto plata wo
bienvenido wunschplatz sich das paar für
morgen heute nacht schlafen sie im hotel
macht eine glückliche nacht in paradies
nächste woche in unsere hochzeit serie
andrea wald geschäft in china
während ihre schwiegereltern endlich ihr
stöckli beziehen können
[Musik]
christian hilfiger und manuela egger
üben ihren hochzeitstanz christian reich
lässt sich in der dominikanischen
republik von bieren weniger verwöhnen
und aldiana um treten lassen es an ihrem
polterabend nochmals so richtig krachen
ja ich will heute in einer woche
[Musik]
ja ich will heiraten in der schweiz
präsentiert von amag